Remember how the Google repository
provided access to a number of
Google services, but
in order to use them we needed to
be certain that the user's device
had the STK up to date and enabled.
You want to check that this is true
before attempting to make a call to
any Google services.
And more importantly you want
to build in graceful failures.
So do you recall how when we were
learning Google Cloud Messaging I
mentioned that there were two
approaches to doing this check?
For GCM we check if the SDK is available
when the app activity is created.
And if so,
we register to receive messages.
But if this registration doesn't happen,
the user never gets
a severe weather alert.
But they also never know that they
are missing out on the feature.
The other approach was to
perform the check at the moment
when you are about to make the API call.
And this could allow you to display
different layouts depending on
the results of that call.
And that is just what we want to do for
the place's API integration.
Ideally, a user should not even know
that they may be missing out on
the place picker.
That means that we need
to structure our UI so
this features only appears
to users who can use it.
So, let's take at how we can build
our location preference dynamically.